[Music]
hi I'm Katie I'm shantam and we're here
with Dean Lev to talk about being back
at school great to be here with you Dean
Levan what are you most excited about
for this new year we have a new business
government Society initiative all about
how do we come together across different
disciplines students faculty alumni and
think about big challenges facing the
world of business and broader society
and what are you most excited about this
year honestly so much I would say first
just really excited to be back on campus
and continue to spend time with our
classmates as you know we have such a
diverse and unique class and so
continuing to Foster those relationships
is a number one priority Dean Lovin what
do you see the role of business in
shaping a more sustainable future last
year we started the Stanford door School
of sustainability it's one of the
biggest things that has happened at
Stanford in many years incredibly
exciting and as part of that we launched
a whole set of initiatives with the door
School upped our joint degree programs
had take Joint appointments conferences
new classes Global study trips and a new
ecopreneurship program which has the
idea of bringing people together from
across campus to start climate oriented
New Ventures will AI make its way into
the GSB curriculum and what kind of AI
tools are we thinking about my belief is
that we are going to um be a place where
a lot of the great discussions happen
about what can this technology enable
about what are some of the risks that
are going to come with it and
disruptions how do we deal with those
thoughtfully and responsibly and give
you all the skills and the tools to
think about how can these tools be used
for business success but also to make
people's lives better here and all over
the the planet so you're back on campus
your MBA 2s you've had an entire year at
the GSB what is your advice for the new
students for me it's about building
community and doing it at your own pace
when I came here I was so anxious to see
all these new faces and I was always a
little bit scared to ask someone to go
on a walk or coffee because I thought
everybody was so busy but just take a
deep breath and realize that they're
waiting for that invite and one walk
might just be the start of a fantastic
relationship that'll last a lifetime I
love that Katie how about you just be
willing to step outside of your comfort
zone and take risks there are so many
opportunities here at the GSB and so I
highly recommend just connecting with
new people doing something you wouldn't
otherwise this is one of the most
special experiences we're going to have
in our lifetimes and so definitely think
we should take advantage of it and have
fun love having you back for your second
Year Dean Levan word on the street is
you attended the Taylor Swift concert
this summer with your family two
questions one did you make friendship
bracelets and two what was your concert
highlight we bought tickets at the
absolute last minute so I did not have
time to make my own friendship bracelet
but luckily my daughter had made extra
so I did get to wear one highlight from
the concert was just being there with
68,000 fans who were completely immersed
in Taylor Swift is an unbelievable
performer and maybe we'll even get her
here Taylor if you're watching we'd love
to invite you the GSB maybe you could
interview her and view from the top oh
we would love to we'd love to we'll hold
you to
that great I'm really looking forward to
De thank you Katie thank you
shantam